[Music]
[Music]
hello hello everybody what is up we made
it we are here Persia here GameSpot
lives and clockwork is in the building
today we're checking out some Power
Rangers battle for the grid we've got
some new characters we got a new patch
we got all the goodness and you guys are
even gonna get a chance to play a
giimpse clock online today so definitely
check that out we're gonna be talking
all about the new goodness stuff coming
up very very soon in the future for all
you Evo goers out there and yeah we're
just looking forward to a clock is back
this is the second time here patron in
the game which means obviously there's
just a lot of awesome stuff in general
on the way for this game and that has
already come out so if you guys are
curious about the DLC it is up there's
free DLC there's already been cute
characters released for this game
absolutely free and then the newest
season one characters that were checking
out today are paid so tell us about what
we have so far hey so this is my good
friend yes so this is version 1.3 right
and we have our first round of paid DLC
characters starting with gold Zeo and
time horse pink so and it comes with a
host of changes as well one of which is
we have the new crossover excuse me the
new tag takeover so if you notice that I
think before so the way that tags work
in this game is that you call your
assist and you press the assist button
again and
and so now we have a sort of a little
VFX if your player one it's blue if your
players red de que tengo switched right
and I mentioned this I think last week
on that in the office where I think my
concern was so one of the favorite my
one of my favorite things about the
system in this game is that if you can
use the takeover system for sort of like
tricky mix-ups right so if I call time
first pink and I jump over right I can
suddenly switch and start a tractor from
behind and so what I was concerned about
is that if we added this little the
effect so with version 1.3 before we get
into the characters we have a host of
changes and improvements by the way the
the patch notes are sort of like a
laundry list oh my goodness yeah I was
looking at the patch notes and I was
like there's so there's a lot well it
almost seems like a new game so I will
say that if you know it'll take us
forever we just go through like each one
one by one but if you want to see the
complete list of patch notes you can go
to battle for the grid comm we're
already getting friend invites yeah so
if you go to battle for the grid comm go
select that the new section you'll see
all the 1.3 changes so it kind of breaks
down not only the system-wide changes
but also the character by character
changes right but I can just run you
guys through some of the more notable
changes one of which is the assistive
over
and also one of the things that we've
improved it's sort of the camera shake
right so we've added a bit more camera
shake to each hit right lights do a
little bit and heaviest do a bit more
sort of just gives more oomph and in
true power rangers fashion we have
weapon attacks making sparks flies oh
nice
Red Ranger here I'm doing medium kick
right and this is light but if I do
heavy with the sword in bruges yeah
really
and some other major changes there have
been some system changes where certain
moves are easier to OTG from off the
ground my fighting game language this is
a wall bounce knockdown right here right
but if you notice I when he lands face
first on the floor if I switch to Jason
and I'll be able to OT G with the Souper
so sort of like opens up the compost
yeah so again check out the patch notes
1.3 on battle for the bridge calm
there's like a ton of a ton of notes
also some new ko visuals right we have
new crouching hit reactions we've also
made changes to push block so again I
mean the game has been out for a few
months now but we are dedicated to
continually improving the game and I
really again appreciate the support from
all the fans and all the players out
there yeah it's this is the reason why
we do it right yeah I mean this is
already the second you know major patch
plus DLC that's been added to the game
so if you didn't know the game has been
released it's here check it out and if
you you know are seeing all the new
additions and changes then you know that
it's not too late to get into it if a
lot of people feel that way about games
sometimes like it's been out for a while
it's a little daunting people already
been playing but it's obviously changed
so much that you know you can pick it up
anytime
and then for the people who have been
playing you know get back in the lab
because things have changed and there's
new characters to live up to so yeah
it's a good time to get into it I kind
of just assumed everyone in the chat
well you know really quick breakdown you
know Power Rangers battle for the grid
3v3 fighting game I think um what's
really unique about our game is that we
do not have motions to do special moves
right so our button layout is light
medium heavy and to do special moves we
have a special button you can do neutral
special forward special right and back
special yeah and it's it's it's a really
good sort of like good beginners
fighting game just you don't worry about
sort of the execution but still has all
the deep mechanics that fighting game
players and who doesn't know about Power
Rangers it's like even if you didn't
watch it you know whose Power Rangers
are exactly we get onto that the new
characters now so if you guys have not
seen any of the recent trailers we have
one point three which is gold Zeo Time
Force pink and award yeah brains showing
and everything right so I'll go over the
new characters first this is gold Zeo
actually micawber time for Stanford so
time for [ __ ] you know we had to the
computer in the game huge fan favorite I
believe the first Pink Ranger leader of
Power Rangers so she's definitely
someone that we had to have in the game
has this sort of like dual wield thing
going on right yeah
and also she snapped I put the blades
together to be some sort of a single
single blade attack right so time for
spin she is like a an aggressive
character so she's the first character
in the game that has an heir - yeah I
was thinking I was watching you do it
and I was like yeah rack my brain about
it yeah but no that's how you yeah so
and again like I feel like most of her
game revolves around this air - move and
it really opens up sort of like offense
right mix-ups
and she has a new mechanic she's the
first character that has an air gets
attacked it's early attack so here's the
air - and if I press the e^x input which
is light and special in after doing the
air test I'm getting yeah we'll get to
it we'll get to the limit all my matches
in a bit if you do that yes yeah she's
just like a time power
so if I cross up and yeah I can sort of
good luck blogging that game yeah and if
i delay my my input here she crosses up
the other way right so these are her
likes so her special moves her first
move is the vault and she's kind of
unique in that the vault is a two two
pronged attack so if I press it once she
vaults over and of course I can use this
for mix up like so used my time work out
of it at the bottom right and also if I
press it twice
it's my anti-air right so she sort of I
can jump cancel that and I can scramble
boss I feel like she's gonna be a cuz it
seems like it'll be easy to confirm into
the anti-air or into a mix of if they're
close and jumping to you like that yeah
every combo her combo routes are really
easy as well so I feel like we're really
getting to know or getting you're so
familiar with the vault attack is this P
and also it's all right there on
accident I think you can get pretty low
oh yeah for low right so if I have my
opponent blocking assist just right in
there right so her back special are
these mortar blasts to more please
elaborate you need to create a game by
Wright and McGill I believe yeah five of
these and it's a really good way what
works well with the system because if I
call if I'm doing this and I call Jason
out right I can tag yeah the blasts are
still coming down
and it's really good for it's versus as
well right and it's really good for take
over the students laughs on the street
for so long if she has a few out and she
gets hit do they stay out okay good
question
Pachulia varmint we're asking the
correct questions so the way that it
works in this version is that if I am on
point and I get hit then they stay out
however it's an assist and I hit her but
if she starts on point and does it and
then you switch to that and she gets it
I believe if she starts on point and the
point is that if she calls yeah if you
pose a blast you sort of have to earn it
where you kind of have to keep your
opponent busy or punish them for trying
to punish your time for spam that kind
of thing right
her forwards are her neutral special she
throws her throws her weapon and comes
forward and back and what's really good
about this attack is that it's good for
combos can you control it or just come
to knock please at the same pace yes
same same same timing no matter what but
what's really good about this projectile
is that it has really high durability so
you've got it all folks
I swear that you can think afterwards is
their meter burn in this game after
Derek O'Neill is absolutely meter burned
so there are a few ways to spend meter
you can do your ax attack which serves
as sort of like a reversal for those
you're familiar fighting it's like a
shoryuken which is this so it has a bit
of invincibility caustic off lumbar and
because it has invincibility you use it
as a defensive maneuver when you're
getting up right you can also use ten
combos
super very nicely I mean in theory yeah
yeah so you know her typical combos are
gonna be like ground chain the fancy
stuff you can learn this palm block from
I can do it you could do it so I would
say you know she's uh she's really good
at mix up mixing up oh sorry excuse me
to answer your question at home the
other ways to use meter are what wait
one X right we also have something
called swap strike right and this is
actually one of the fastest attacks in
the game you can also use it offensively
it's invincible
oh thanks or no it's invincible but it
does cost meter and it is fungible
gotcha right so you can't use it as a
reversal and it's really fast but if it
gets blocked fairness and of course the
other way is super super cost two bars
and for those of you just tuning in
we're going over the new characters if
you want to learn more about the actual
patch notes just go to battle for the
grade calm and we will be playing some
matches against you guys at home so
don't forget stick around for that
the in way ID is in way underscore games
hashtag fifty to sixty yeah and I know a
lot of people have been adding me
already I will get some more so we will
get there but we got to talk about these
characters I mean we're only talking
about the first one so far but she's
already looking pretty good it's cool no
it's any any game like this with such
frenetic gameplay needs an air -
character right really time for spin
she's gonna be a character where if you
master
how to user air - and all softies the
time-warp stuff wouldn't even the air -
right that's the third piece being
successful with her pool so next is bull
geo gold zero in my opinion he's my
favorite part
shame yeah so these are his lights so I
would say gold Zeo he's he's kind of
like I think the the idea for gold Zeo
is that we wanted another character that
had the same agility as red Rangers he
is pretty easy pretty fast he's I want
to say loose but he's very agile very
responsive right so I would say gold Zeo
sort of has the same feeling with the
dashes and you can see the difference
here it's time for pink her her dashes
are much slower you know a bit more
sluggish I mean if she was any faster
I'd really start design choices over
there I suppose suppose if that's your
one weakness that's not bad
yes so he's kind of like a more
technical red ranger whereas red ranger
and green ranger of those have played
the game know that these characters are
pretty easy to play you know just do
those specials and supers that kind of
thing
the jungle combos are very simple but
with gold Zeo you kind of have to do a
little bit of homework for his combos
which I'll get into the bid so special
moves bold and pulse on on the actual
show he often uses this as like a
finisher okay this story like the baddie
of the week but in this game it's a
special move it's a little bit sluggish
but you can't cancel it into his other
special that's right oh nice yeah so his
back special golden crush it's probably
my favorite animation of all of the real
deal animations just kind of like a
double kick goes a pretty good distance
yeah about full screen it is a bit slow
but on block it is safe and on hit I can
say it covers a pretty good range - yeah
yeah so the idea is that if you manage
to get the golden pulse off so I think
the cornerstone of his gaming is the
lord of salt which is the for special
for those of you who are familiar with
the source material Fulvio he often does
this move where he sort of like both a
juju juju around he just turned into a
blur so that's sort of the same idea
alright that's the idea behind this move
is that he can yeah open up a lot of
mobility tools and also use them for
pumpkins as well so Lords install it
sports special you can also go forward
back can go for back up I can go forward
a forward right for that back and I can
also cancel I can fall in the back right
and similar to Time Force pink where if
I do
Mary - children delay my attack she
turns around mm-hmm
turn around nice so the way that this
moves works is that every - sort of has
a hit so you can do juggle combos like
cetera et cetera
and if I press for its special twice I
do gold rush anyone any gold zeal fans
no iconic gym also called the pier -
Laura yeah oh my god - vault attack so
the way his super works is that it's a
it's a two two volleys of lightning
attacks right so the first one goes
forward and back and then the second one
sort of comes a lightning bolt down so
it doesn't combo on its own however it's
up to the player - yeah mix that with
everything else you go so I can make
this combo right
[Laughter]
and again the point of this the point of
the super is that you can either decide
to combo the whole thing or I can mix up
right and so when it comes to the mix-up
I can stop the combo like half way so if
I do something like this right mix-up or
third time's the charm I can get the
whole thing got this no pressure
so it's it's open-ended in that it's a
super that is meant to be for trick it
it's open-ended in that I can go for the
damage I can go for the mix-up or it's
one of the few super psychics throw well
if I want to get something started have
some recovery so something that you'll
have to do a little bit of fun right so
I would say bread-and-butter combos with
this guy you want to do this ground
change to HHH and then catch withstand
em
if you like if you like Green Ranger if
you like Ranger oh special so the air
special is interesting because this is a
move that we we sort of played around
with during you know while iterating on
it originally was a dive cake so if you
noticed like he kind of looks like he's
doing a dive kick ya figure that's a
little boring so let's let's try
something else with this so what he does
is that during this whole animation he
is unlike the Lord default he's not
doing an attack however it could be used
for mixes right so he goes through the
opponent when he does it
so I can do things like jumping attack
on the other side I can also cancel my
attacks into it side right and so the
other thing too is I can use it in my
combo so if I do like using my yeah yeah
is there a height restriction so the
thing is it doesn't restriction so if I
do it like an inch off the ground
nothing happens great okay okay but if I
do it up here you know it's fine
however the height restriction is taken
off if I cancel into this so I can do it
inch off the ground if I do like that
yeah so really good for mix ups as long
as I touch I can cancel into and
have fun [ __ ] that do you Boldin
pulse I can do deeper Lawrence twice or
three times so I would say Gould zero is
the character that he's really tricky
he's a bit technical right so learning
some of the more advanced combos like
this right I'll take a bit of homework
yeah when he's like recovering there
after the - yeah what's his recovery
like I yeah pretty bad yeah cuz even
though you hit her it looked like yours
your recovery was still pretty bad yeah
I think what's the optimal finisher
after it was actually so I would say
that so if I just walk and she blocks
this I kind of have to I get like a
little bit of time to confirm in which
case okay and do your legs move if I
block I can go I can go up and that can
go forward and try to promote I can also
go forward back and then I can council I
can also go forward back and up and are
all the directions recovery different
like it's up when I have a little bit
better recovery it looks like it has
like yes all the air ones are I would
say maybe like five frames
holds eel players into a high level play
they need to be good at hit confirming
block spacing yeah because you don't
really want to go for some of the more
guarantees he's a character he's you
know really good at rest on in fact I
would say both genin trading
and he's also a character that really
likes to eat
so we've decreased meter gain across the
board I think twice now Jani torretta
Everett appeals race so you do need a
character so I mean these new characters
and again this is version 1.3 if you see
the trailer you know that Lord Zedd is
coming we will show them off at a later
date I'm really excited to see where
people I know actually all three of
these characters have been sort of fan
favorite characters that people see what
you want you I heard your point your
your port your vote counts and so it was
really important that we have a tonic
yeah yeah well I'm off hopefully be back
here yeah again 1.3 it's our first paid
DLC part of the season one pass so those
of you that see one pass
he's available now the DLC is available
on switch and Xbox right now ps4 will be
coming shortly and a new feature that we
have not yet talked about is end wave in
way place so those people those
notifications pop up people are adding
us on em we play so yeah let's talk more
about that because I think that's super
cool and yeah let's spill so what anyway
play is it's a way for you know very
basically for us to cross right so
currently we have cross play in 1.3
available or Nintendo switch and Xbox so
we're on we're playing on xbox right now
so on your right trigger here right
here's your anyway play console and I
already got a bunch of friend requests
from people that want to play I'm having
everybody let's play some games yeah
people and so what it does is you know
it gives us a way for you to connect
Nintendo players with Xbox players and
and also a way to do direct match yeah
so that's pretty freakin hype if you ask
me oh we got a challenge already a
challenge do you guys know what you're
getting yourselves into of course you do
it's clockwork let's do this playing on
bet I mean you guys know he's a hitbox
player now play on Pat no never I
started on stick yeah I cannot use pad
save my life I've tried my brain does
not work when I'm using a pad so I've
always played on stick it's just the way
it is but yeah I think cross-play super
awesome definitely a great way to like
it the whole community like together to
play and this is like a system that you
guys yourselves created so I think
that's also worth mentioning too because
they're not only supporting the game
creating more content but they're also
actively trying to find more comfortable
and smoother ways for everyone to play
against each other to it so that's
pretty cool
hey I know getting a lot of invites
right now we'll get to as many matches
as we can yeah we've got like an hour we
got plenty of time for you guys these
hands
[Laughter]
like last time you were here I was
showing you come when you're like I
didn't even know that work and I was
like I learned this off Twitter like an
hour ago are you in the chat right now
really might be might be so yeah Fred
next our guys are gonna be playing some
matches against you so if you want to
play you see the ID on your screen it's
in Wayne underscore games hashtag 50 to
60 avatar that's how you know he's been
in a lab he probably just ripped your
combo you just showed twos about to hit
you with it
[Laughter]
tell me what you got I'm starting on
point but yes Calico in the chat and we
are comfy we're gonna new features and
contents more is on the way which is
actual factual first match against the
viewers
uh-oh Dumont oh I do like the sparks so
now that it's all in action I think the
sparks is definitely a nice touch
yeah you guys look pretty similar if you
like the gold is just a slight different
hint of gold ooh
oh it's madness it's madness gotta
respect the lightning oh man Dumont
making a statement first games de Buci
game says Dumont Sabine to be on the
lookout
Oh
whippin in the corner though alright we
got this we got this
hey it's under control it's all that's
left let me see this show Green Ranger
always beats gold are right this is
gonna be cannon
oh [ __ ] oh yeah I'm from the Hemnes good
clutch that oh oh oh boy now play the
mixtape real quick that drop this fire
real quick get out of here
cannon oh oh
Danger Danger
we're not alone sorry I'll be LV oh we
got the lead now Oh Dumont Dumont yeah
had to kick it up a notch
[Laughter]
but Dumont those good men yeah two out
of three I think we can run well but
we'll do it two out of three yeah we'll
do 203 unless we have like more than ten
invites because and I think we might run
out of time we want to get those as many
people as possible
oh just kidding one and done
one and done starting now Ashley New
York yeah
challenges Oh challenges yes go catfight
but yeah we see you guys in the chat a
lot of awesome and loyal Power Rangers
supporters people I've seen who've been
like you know definitely helping out
with the spreading the info on Twitter
and stuff like that which games catfight
a bunch of other people I've like been
also watching videos and stealing combos
from on Twitter all time there's also a
discord if you guys want to check out
the discord for battle for the grid
that's a thing too many but we're too
popular yeah the the ambush yeah of
course of course
ooh calico said cat will crush you
o'clock that you challenger I don't
believe in getting crushed all right
here we go
Omega black fgc stepping up picking our
new characters here alike
um I don't think you can put links in
the chat and actually but if you head
over to Twitter and follow at battle
number four the grid I think I can type
that in here
alright this is available on switch for
those asking which is awesome and slowly
becoming like a twitch you know person I
mean that switch switch person in
general because I'm like man the switch
has everything now you know the neutral
jumps don't add a frozen sudhana
still one of my favorites
oh I'll be fireball wake up scrub I do
it this pressure
keep-away action a little bit of you pew
pew oh my goodness stay back go make a
black protection we've got we don't want
to let her in gamespot stream you put
your shoes right you gotta bring your A
game here
you're so annoying it's great though
that's why you use these characters so
I'm giving him the fgc dang dragons oh
whoa oh my goodness Donna resting
[Music]
yeah the power rooms is awarded oh my
goodness hey relax wake up dad nice game
we'll make a black and then you got like
the big boys in the back stage fighting
- it's just a brawl all around town I
feel like it's I it's not too many
fighting games
yeah it's tuned I think it's something
that you know all games need we don't
need this divide it's time to come
together y'all all right yeah you know
the chance here I want to say today ooh
calling out the stream well Creighton
Kaliko not if you faced off against
black cat we're gonna have to get that
magic we'll see about that
Oh oh my god
oh you got Christmas on me
that's not going to get out of there go
no I needed that guy oh my god was I
playing against the younger sibling last
match oh I'll make a black is that
turning it up
Oh No
oh I didn't need to do that hey we got
this
No
oh no thanks haha
come back oh goodness
yeah what happened - we're gonna get
zero long - I met after this match the
comeback oh my god yep
run it back
you men overall lawsuit tonight within
the say you know two and three still
zero sets but yeah as you guys can see
already some good competition in this
game and new characters big patch so
it's a great time to pick it up if
you're interested more more another
update coming soon with Lords that among
other things yes and even some cool
events coming up which we'll talk about
later as well so we're worried about
this one this one two one right now yeah
exactly this is all online I mean you
commentators cursed yourself
all right all the marbles clocks go an
extra try hard mode now it was like no
way you tonight just be be at my own
game like this I need this guy ouch it
hurts now you know what is actually my
favorite thing about having claw come
and like show off the characters and
then plays hope you like yeah this is
totally unsafe and then he does it the
exact like no idea
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think I found some makeup I finally
make a box weaknesses okay yeah this
corner yeah there we go yeah everybody
got a worried you're gonna scooped up Oh
Dean no cool
I saw your life flash before presence
point yeah
make it count though cuz you know that
e^x is just being churned right now
[Laughter]
are you now good thing there's a stream
building oh no I only have a meter for
the car we just went over this plug the
one the one is big so much pressure on
you right now oh my god
[ __ ] whoo oh my god
yeah he needs some help please the sword
the movement though okay nice Scott
about it oh nice
the meaty ice got some protection Oh
punish that okay don't choke don't chug
this last character Oh
Gooden even get in the match nice games
GG's clock stayed alive next next
Challenger oh he is in here I'll make a
black end a nice games yeah whoo all
these requests everybody wants to play
some benefit agreed spread the word you
guys tell your friends the play you know
people on switch don't be scared tell me
another one cafe people are talking you
up I know people that chat talking you
up there we go oh yeah well let me let
me let me accept whatever comes yeah
because I think we're getting the cue
what a Mega Man 2 yes welcome thank you
for tuning in you're right this is
looking fired and more is on the way
still got another character on the way
and in a lot of secret magic also on the
way yeah please battle for the grid calm
if you want to check out the 1.3 patch
notes yeah it changed a bunch of stuff
updated a lot of stuff they are
listening to the communities
play it enjoy it and uh let them know
you know give him feedback you know
don't be a Butthead about it but you
know feedback is always welcome
nobody has allowed they said Oh Dan
dodged again oh is catfight get in line
catfight yeah plenty of coffins to go
around yeah the stream delay is about 45
seconds to a minute
so that also adds to the invites timing
out but we got some people in in our
like usual chat we're all who are always
really really good at stream sniping
yeah I know that's what's up man killing
me smalls thoughts have to back out yeah
we're yeah there's no countdown so we
have to make her like you're you're
stuck forever in this Lobby oh you said
it seems to be lagging oh okay okay
maybe sending the moves by yeah on to
the next match oh here we go connection
alright do it find this catfight again
[Laughter]
oh I saw that one that's [ __ ] up all
right catfight
no I didn't work on dropped out yeah I
think all the invites come in at once
yeah freaking it out a little bit okay
we will get to you guys even if the
invites are not working in this moment
we will get there yeah we're getting a
high volume of invites and fight
requests so yeah please be patient with
us I'm not dodging I'll take all of you
along at once at once and for people
asking about PC news don't worry guys on
the way it's on track but you're just
gonna have to be patient with the squad
but if you and everything they can so
you know and please follow us on all the
social right and weigh games battle for
the grid you can follow me on VC
clockwork we will let everyone know
about solid dates as soon as they come
out for future updates and for PC
release this is the fun part about
having clock come and play because he's
like oh I'll just use someone else
definitely better with some characters
than others but don't worry cat fine
we'll make sure clock does not leave
this building until you guys play you
put them to the test
is this game old absolutely not I would
say it's still pretty fresh all right
here we go back at it
dang this is this is rough get punished
we will we will try once more
ballin please how about this cat fire
I'm gonna challenge you ooh
he said I'm bringing a fight - you
alright calf are you ready I'm gonna
give it a minute okay let's try it the
direct challenge has been sent
just because cat fight is getting hyped
up in the chat I know a thing where
where is the ad now come on it's
possible to the cafe we just don't have
a good connection between the two of us
so hopefully
and he's like there we go yeah it's like
now you're like okay going in today like
right I'm gonna play the cheapest team I
know I'm with all the secret tech you're
gonna use the characters with the patch
notes that haven't been released yet
I'll see you hold our time too bad for
you I specialize in shutting down Goldar
I'm sure see the show gold are never
wins never win
you hungry can in here yeah
but cat plays cat which is fitting and
wonderful I was using her for a bit
she's fun cat's pajamas this game was
made for you cafe 285 huh we'll see
about that such a death my whole career
see about that okay I'm actually really
high it because there's a lot of buildup
in chat for this match a lot of
disconnects and dodges but we made it
look at the patients right now Oh coz
his career o'clock oh the pressure nice
ooh big with you know cafe I'm gonna
totally encourage the one and done if
you lose
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh nice you don't have to evade that
strap again that shoulder though see
it's like the move of choice okay cat's
eye I actually when they see this play
it cat's eyes getting balls in the
corner right now I can't do anything
what are you gonna do okay he's finally
gonna calm boys oh boy
you know despite how long you had him in
the corner you stay alive
the sustain oh oh okay the patience he's
just waiting for the opportune moment
oh my goodness all big with blemish it's
okay it's cool I kind of felt like he
just needed to go no matter what but you
still got the second wave of the super
that's pretty good oh yeah that's
something different in this compared to
other like vs fighters you're doing a
super the next character will come out
it won't wait until the end yeah
oh dang cha oh no man you guys are
getting pretty hype but this is looking
pretty pretty free like I can't even
breaking a sweat
okay whoo Oh whoo g'day let's run it
back ready back as I say one in time
doing I really like I gold our combo
yeah I think if you landed a super I
would have been a hundred percent yeah
like what's up booty gains you over here
being a hype man for catfight hey what's
up firebrand of Phoenix I got the stream
a bit the other day thanks for streaming
battle for the grid man shoutouts to the
AZ crew some of the easy guys don't
disappoint me oh now you have the fresh
air don't disappoint the legend versus
fighting a mayor himself oh Jesus I'm
jumping out of the sky I'm not gonna
drop it
Oh goodbye oh no you're alive get off of
me you're alive BX this is what the
meters were built for oh nice the Blue
Ranger has invited you to play battle
for the grid that's how you know it's
real
oh he tried to punish you in between is
there a gap there
it does it goes left her might is it
yeah we got protection here what are you
doing the Lord is helping how we're up
Oh get out of here
given success Oh what like wake up TV's
on another level
woo noise like this oh alright Blue
Ranger we get it man
we're in a battle here get in the area
can diversion though ah the bounce
walk please
blues nope your life though megazor
survive survive
or not ie you have yours right now
though it's not over yet oh the
conversion Oh stomp on him oh I love a
little kick you just add such character
all the delay lows can't fight you
deserve that I would have done it too I
would have spent a bar to get out - OH
GG's DG's games Kfir nice combos man
yeah that was good stuff yeah a few
drops that would have changed
yeah the fate of that match for so super
hey nice games what else you got for me
chat yeah right let's get the next
victim in here I like quadrupled my
friend count bleeder right blue leader
okay
whoo yeah that was a good one that was
indeed good one yeah guys the scheme and
Alice game is poppin yeah please
again the end way play ID if you want to
add and try to get some games in its
anyway underscore games hashtag 52 to
1560 it's only right and rid of my face
on the screen but you know Vento oreo
let's go man
see what you got
let's get um a roll call in the chat
have you ever heard of evo and are you
going evo a meaning evolution the
greatest and biggest fighting game
tournament in the world it is less than
a month away right now it is August 2nd
through the 4th in Las Vegas at the
Mandalay Bay and you know fighting
advance definitely the place to be then
so has the Dragon shield
how much is the game the game is 20
bucks 20 bucks y'all which if you think
about a lot of that begins out right now
that's not bad at all
some loop action oh yeah we got a lot of
people in the chat going to Evo that's
exciting definitely looking forward to
it
and uh yeah I'm looking forward to
having some fun
the first year in a while that I'm not
actually working the event but I will be
there to support EXO EXO Academy player
and play games actually like that's the
biggest thing about going to the event
to work it you don't get much time to
actually yeah absolutely every time
every time
[Applause]
Chad says $20 is basically free exactly
pretty much must be a marvelous noise
I'm liking the combos she's looking very
fancy schmancy hey Roman I have a very
very quick tournament story
oh yeah Roman asks does clock have any
funny tournaments I have a lot of really
short one since I'm playing I was
definitely playing in a Marvel -
tournament an FFA around 2008 and I
remember it was one one and a freaking
fly flew into my mouth so managed to win
that match though oh my god that's oh
sorry I think I hit I hit leave match
sorry whoever I just played oh yeah my
bad a fat finger did you're thinking
about that fly in your mouth and you're
like I can't sorry what nice games
anybody else wants it who wants some
technique
Tetsuo he's also in the shot and thinks
definitely wants to play but might have
expired oh we got a cheat who's also in
the chat but he has sent his request Oh
No
well maybe you should start sending the
invites out because we have a long list
of friends yeah we do we do we do
Oh
are there any games I'm playing this
year well I mean honestly I've been
playing a lot of games just not fighting
games but it's been a it's been fun
though because you know as someone who's
played like just games in general all my
life and then going through like a
decade of fighting games only it's kind
of nice to go back to playing like you
know regular games and like to revisit
that feeling of like the satisfaction of
like 100 percent in a game or completing
like a story mode for something or it
depends on the game but yeah like for
example like Spider Man like there's a
lot of stuff in that game it's not
necessarily like hard to 100% it's just
time consuming compared to a game like
Shover saves the universe I 100% percent
of that game but that took me like less
than a day very much so just depends on
the game but it's fun satisfying right
go yeah shoutouts the StuCo man is
always posting tech not only for battle
for the grid by other fighting games hey
guys if you're in the chat and you sent
a friend request maybe let us know what
your idea is so when we send challenges
out we make sure we get to everybody
who's in the chat
yeah we've got about 20 minutes left of
the stream but we'll still try to get as
many people in as possible even if we go
a little bit over time
yeah StuCo it's been a while man
actually I've employed you in this yet
yeah rocky Yuki says I'm just casually
playing games which I should be grinding
for Evo Evo's not far away man cat fight
this is gonna make an all-in challenge
clock and get his revenge he's gonna be
the hard combo that I was doing she's
wild look at this monster you created is
the - coasters done woo got her big
chunk got the toes so light though oh
yeah yeah you're like you're dropping
that I'm using her meter every time
the entire and the loop looky-loo oh
yeah he's trying to impress you he's
like I mean without all the hardest
stuff no almost
we're like a third hit in there
somewhere finish your plate this time
oh yeah it's fun for that read this oh
it's still work no I didn't work
oh man
oh no don't birthday meet those super Oh
[Music]
Blue Ranger here he's a part of the two
free DLC characters yeah so sign is a
Blue Ranger black dragon tree knee or
excuse me dragon armor tree and gone on
a from mystic force free DLC so right
when you get the game they are readily
available as well as you know vio story
mode yeah the first the first update is
a huge content update available right
now yeah so after this let's get
technique in here we haven't played
against Eggman yet and then we also have
ball and plays yeah shredder zero the
cross play is now live and if I had to
guess I was probably playing against a
few switch players that we're on Xbox
cool playing against Xbox and switch
players right now
new connections I mean we had that one
drop out but yeah nice yeah stucco was
playing on switch we were playing on
xbox and it was a pretty smooth match so
I'm excited I know they're breaking your
character best thing about fighting
games even if you're dropping in it's
like keep going for it anyway because
then when you do land it it's the only
way to really implement it in our game
oh yeah that lasted the overhead right
little tricky things Lou if they didn't
friend he and given to the Bates yep Oh
I nice conversion
do it
[Laughter]
oh man oh my god it's terrifying it's
like a shotgun commander oh oh goodbye
oh oh my god just have to survive so you
can use our sword make it count
oh my god I don't she's charging it up
ok she's adding years old oh snap you
gotta hit this
she's my dad come oh gosh also boyfriend
really advanced combos right that was
very choppy yeah that was the
breadwinner right there and it would
just slip through the fingers we're
still so good though that was dope nice
games uh yeah let's get technique in
here you're up next technique I'm gonna
invite you
mm-hmm but yeah catfight says hey
feraldo absolutely love this game and
really appreciate people like clock
shady calico and meow are for getting
involved with the community and doing
stuff like this y'all the best hey I'll
see you man
playing with playing with the viewers
yeah how does it feel to like be like
hey everyone let's play this game I made
and then you just get bombarded with
like 50 in by its within the minute yeah
we good at testing the limits of anyways
he's doing pretty well pretty well we
know what sick is that Hugo is doing
like combo routes that I'd never seen
before you know I'm like the air - I'm
good a juggle it's cool to see you know
we've designed the game and the
characters to be open-ended to the point
where you know we can my drag is not
GG's StuCo he said he is heading back to
the lab oh yeah no surprise level 223
with triple exclamation points the legs
as a Marvel player how does the game
feel as a Marvel game and a scale of 1
to 10 I would see it has similarities to
like a Marvel games but it's definitely
individual and its own like right yeah I
would say the biggest thing to the
ground and only very you know until this
most recent dlc set of characters there
were no air dashes so it's definitely
different I mean has the same elements
in terms like 3v3 and using a SISTAR's
tag it's not backwoods definitely worth
playing just to oh my god have a new
game in your arsenal especially a versus
game if that's your type of thing
I got everybody this is why I love it
when the FGCU comes to a chat right
because now we just have like exhibition
matches unfolding in the chat he said
play me in a person who said that no
among the chat people yeah they're
setting it up amongst themselves and I
like that yeah get it done get it poppin
you guys practice up for Evo because
we're gonna be talking about some cool
happenings for this game that you go
very shortly so we get some matches in
still got some time so I'm gonna be
sending out some in wait
okay yeah babies come back
oh the Megazord Oh Oh your honor aides
the cross under we're gonna have another
comeback showing us the fancy stuff
there watch out now though the sword the
sword is out
Danger Danger no chip doesn't seem right
run it back run it back that first game
first game technique yeah
yeah I was like dang stuff all three
characters yeah I should yeah I think
the strategy is like the killa one and
then actors come on you played marble
yeah I didn't believe in any place
traitor
it's like Christmas Eve yeah oh no I
think we lost connection hold that hold
that
and since we're in our like last 10 15
minutes or so I would say let's just do
one indents with everyone we haven't
tried so let's see that was taking a
good stuff techniques take that w shine
it up real nice put it on your sweaters
Oh Mac little bit Mac attack has been
trying this match for a while hey Mac
attack I'm gonna send you an invite Mac
tax up next let's see I think also
ballin plays wanted to get in there at
some point as well take on the world
yeah yeah we're good
we started a few minutes late so we can
go a few minutes overtime yeah thanks
guys for I think it's actually my first
time testing online on Xbox Oh dating
Stuka with the option selects that's
called an audible can I get a run back
I'll play my actual team I think yeah
Mac attack I think you sent me in okay
oh there we go
there we go oh and then she also wanted
to get a game in here so we'll try to
get a Mac bottom please yuichi games we
got you guys on on the queue yeah it's
been fun you know we're getting towards
the end here feel free to send us some
some questions as well if we don't
answer your question then we probably
answered it already earlier in the
stream in which you know this VOD will
be up on the GameSpot YouTube right
after we're done recording so feel free
to go back to the beginning touch what
you miss cuz we did review the new
characters we didn't go too much into
detail about some of the patch notes
because there's a lot but we did go over
a little bit of it and you can always go
to battle for the grid comm go to the
new section check out the 1.3 patch
notes some of the big Universal changes
right at it some camera shake assist
takeover VFX adjusted some push block
added hit sparks a lot of changes for
individual characters it's a huge list
so please check it out
I like that people already pretty
competent with the DLC characters we see
you out there grinding yeah exactly they
were very recently released not too long
ago
right Mac attack it's your time to shine
but you're gonna happy birthday to right
now hey oh you got nice oh you get it
that's clever
that was super clever that was it boy
nice I like that the transitions are
pretty seamless when you go for like
this when you bring in your secondary
characters it's definitely my favorite
part of the game
you can create a lot of cool missiles
that you otherwise no accident let's see
let's see if I can find the discord link
for you guys I can send it to you
because I know we're talking about a lot
in the chat right now but I know I could
probably be kinda hard nice games oh
that is unfortunate yeah all right but
however here we are putting you the
discard link to battle for the grid in
the chat you know the community is
growing the people who are already in
the community are amazing they're very
helpful when I was you know learning
more about the game and looking for
combos and tips and tricks and stuff
like that everyone's very very helpful
so yeah sorry Mac be good let me let me
give them another chance
thanks for pointing with yeah it's been
fun I think it's just also hilarious
watching you fight against people like
in a game you make is inhuman so that
you're like oh I didn't even know that
word no like that is so funny that's why
you win like you know people have betas
for a reason cuz like yes guys I'm
looking at the game 24/7 you think you
know like the possibilities and then you
put it out into the world the universe
and like what happened do you often have
any not too often you're kind of like
you know the Unicorn
well at least from for me personally I'm
sure there happened in the past before I
started working here I think it's cool
you know bring in the - oh no sorry Mack
we tried and we're gonna try to get to
some of our other players ball and plays
with definitely wanted to play and you
Chi and og games as well
yeah sorry Mac we'll play next time yeah
bond plays if you're still in the chat
[Music]
is out there yeah if you for the viewers
who don't know clockwork here he is a
developer for this game so if you see
all this broken crazy stuff you million
this guy way let me put the camera on
full screen so you know exactly who to
blame this guy right here next time
we're playing online you get hit by some
crazy impossible to blog mixup think of
my shiny ball yeah I think it is awesome
not like the devs come play the game
with the fans and actually you know beat
him up to like that's great yeah you got
to show off the goods the fresh
merchandise
Oh ladies 19 oh yeah of course
yeah lead combat designer which is like
specifically blame him blame shady to
actually sushi which may also expose why
Oh after 17 seconds of analysis the
matchup has been decided
not claim but look at you exposing you
we jump back folks can you walk up bars
anyways just do it oh my goodness
o'clock holy crap
I know Bobby Flay is waiting in the
shadows this whole time holy crap who's
like I cannot wait to freeze you up real
quick Oh cat get out of there girl I
don't think I played the game enough to
have a favorite team Strider at you zero
asks what are your favorite team
but I think you Don is really cool no
she got away get her back in here oh my
goodness
we've done is all of us done for a pill
all no punished no oh my goodness
your lies Oh
oh my goodness please oh that could be
the game changer right there wake up
super fertile at all oh no you better
activate that sword oh my goodness
dad's awake of meter nice black oh okay
oh look you deserve a night hits you I
definitely deserve that nice games
baller plays that does give me so much
trouble to begin with yeah for sure
snow and ice in the face yes good games
and you say clock is getting roasted by
lies lady absolutely am I gonna pick
this game up on the side I mean I played
it a little bit and whenever clock comes
and shows it off and wise like dang I
need to play this
hey you Chi I'm gonna invite you cheese
turn I'm also gonna throw a shout-out to
that time clock said he's gonna get zero
losses on this ones and guns are not
asset oh s still intact
not a cent yeah nice nice ball in place
yeah you Donna's Gucci game says just
FYI were almost had a thousand members
in the disco and once they hit a
thousand they're giving away a switch
code your community is very very
supportive of your game oh yeah I think
we disconnected yeah Sheva said the
discord man like it's a lot of strats a
lot of Power Ranger fandom ball in place
it's in before they nerf food on and
because of me in the music alright this
is gonna be our last match on the stream
you guys but it has been one heck of a
broadcast and thank you all for tuning
in
we saw a few things talk about before we
go but it's been pretty fun today for
sure you know what in for that a little
get what you guys are doing for your
community is pretty awesome I'm gonna
toss up the discord link in there one
more time for you guys join us now I
think when it comes to games in this day
and age especially fighting games
community is everything ya know we play
because we're know when I was when I was
younger I used to get you know still get
a kick out of playing it's to CTU as
single-player games that kind of thing
but I think once I got a taste of
competition yeah and fighting games you
know is all about lumpy ones and you
know community building right mhm so
it's it's really great that we have this
cross play connect the users across time
and get in time and space
yes and in time when all the stars align
and everything comes together then you
know everyone on every pop we're gonna
be able to play together and that's
rewards yeah that's when the
competitions really gonna be furious so
if I could get what I'm thinking to
happen execution Emily everything on
side remove your hands from yeah way
better than I am like in the matrix
where they download the skills they're
like oh I'm gonna need to learn how to
fly a helicopter I did it everything
alright here we go
like I want that in real life Oh mega
black says I appreciate y'all streaming
and putting so much effort in this game
well we appreciate your support and ferp
and for playing the game everything is
yeah the support doesn't stop too you
know with your guys's support we can
keep going you know so shout outs to all
the fans playing the game creating
content for the game tweeting about the
game you know joining in the community
the discord yeah
skillz that killz says ask who wins
between clock and shady no comment oh
and then his follow-up question was and
why does Shady be clocks excite it says
this is sounding like a black mirror
episode oh my goodness that show blows
my mind I can't trust technologies oh my
goodness oh the damage Gucci
oh gee I had to do the dirt the dirt per
her ug my leg you free no I'm just
kidding I'm sorry that was rude hey he
said I don't know what GG is though I
mean that's just the way it is sometimes
but yeah you guys thank you so much for
tuning in today and thank you of course
clockwork for a stop in my studio to you
know show off the brand-new characters
there are now available and there are
the first round of pay of pay DLC but
there are also already a round of free
DLC available so 20 bucks grab yourself
a game how much is it DLC that's a good
question 20 bucks for a DLC or the
season past 20 with a bunch of skins
right the skin characters there's
another character already on the wave so
the support doesn't stop if you are
going to evolution 2019 which is less
than a month away it's gonna be August
2nd through the 4th but at the cross
counter booth you guys will be doing
some shenanigans over there huh yeah so
at the cross-counter booth we are
running tournaments and the winners of
the tournament from I believe Friday and
Saturday will play at the main stage at
bar fights we'll have more details about
you know time and place and all that
place but you know timing and you know
entry and all that in future
announcement for now know that we will
be at evil yeah give us a holler yeah so
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
playing some matches for receiving and
also giving hands this whole stream so
we hope see you guys next time please
keep supporting game join the discord
and just wait alright we'll see you guys
next time
[Music]